thanks for uh coming in after lunch i'll
try to keep the
lunch hangover from hitting you too hard
so let's see before i get started i want
to learn a little bit more about the
people in the room
who in the room is a mobile application
developer
all right and then who works on like
back ends that mobile applications
connect to
right on and then is anyone in the room
a database implementer
all right cool so uh
i've got a lot to cover i'm going to
talk about a
a project that we've recently turned
into a product at couch base but i don't
want to dwell on that i just want to
tell you enough about it so that the
rest of the talk makes sense
i'll show a little bit of a demo and
then i think you know the good geeky
fun part is going to be the data
structures that we actually use
you know on the back end and in the
client to
manage you know tracking distributed
edits so that you
can do conflict emerging without
throwing away data
so if you want another subtitle of this
talk
besides the future of mobile it's a it's
a cheat sheet for if you need to build
your own synchronization
solution um you know what data structure
you need to use anyway
and hopefully that convinces you to grab
an off-the-shelf
synchronization solution
so yeah uh my name is chris anderson
you can follow me on twitter at j chris
i'm a co-founder of couchbase i've been
working on distributed database problems
since like 2008
and for mobile we started you know down
this journey
in mid 2010 so we've been working on it
for a long time
and recently we got to the point where
couchbase has actually announced a
product and you know shipping code
so you can go download all the stuff i'm
talking about today
so our strategy with this big
this big mess of a slide
what it says here is that is that you've
got json anywhere
so that means that as uh
you know as an application developer
rather than translating
you know your mobile app wants to
consume json from an api and your
database
you know wants to store json hopefully
you know you're in the in the nosql
future already
and rather than doing a bunch of
translation in an application layer
you can just stream that data to and
from
the client via you know synchronization
protocol
that i'll talk a little bit about so
the product that we are
you know we released last week the the
mobile
embedded database is called
couchbaselight
and what it has you know sort of unique
about it is that it's written from the
ground up for ios and android to be
you know native on those platforms so
you know we've done experiments with
taking existing databases
and getting them you know to run on
mobile devices but
that's not the same thing as being
mobile first and writing code that
is you know in objective-c or in java
and designed
to run you know lean on the platform
so there are kind of three pieces to the
overall architecture if you go to deploy
an app like this and it's a little bit
different from
the uh you know traditional uh
three-tier application but
but there's some echoes of what you'll
be familiar with so a database server on
the back end for storage
and an embedded database a nosql json
database
you know in your user's hand and then in
between
we have a sync gateway and we call it
that because it enables synchronization
but we
call it a gateway because it enables
fine-grained access control
and it gives you the ability to route
data to the users who care about it
so what this looks like is you can
deploy
your couch-based server you know
anywhere you want a lot of our users
have it in the cloud
a lot of them keep it on premise depends
on what your performance requirements
are mostly
and in front of that you'll put sync
gateway this sits where like a
traditional application tier would sit
so you exposed it to the internet you
would never expose your database to the
internet
at least i hope that's not you know the
normal way you do things
and so the sync gateway then
makes sure that people are only you know
doing things to the database that you
approve of
it's a little bit like an application
server in that regard but it's not like
an application server
because you don't have to write it you
just install it
and then on the device there's the
embedded nosql database that
is you know lightweight we're targeting
roughly half a megabyte of you know
additional download size that your app
would have
by including it so couch-based light
that database is you know designed
really from the ground up to be
lightweight and to be as secure as
possible on the mobile platform
and it's been written for ios and
android
and one of the design constraints we we
had is that we needed a common api
between those applications
between those platforms and that's
because i'm kind of addicted to
phonegap not everyone on my team is
there's a lot of
you know native partisans but i like to
be able to write it once in javascript
and
you know a web view and deploy it
wherever so you can
you know add a rest kind of facade layer
optionally in front and access the
database via ajax calls from your
webview
it's a document database so everything's
json
you can do all your all your work you
know locally on the device
and the thing we'll talk about when we
get to the data structures just sort of
why i'm rushing this portion of the talk
because
i want to talk about the data structures
for a while is conflict
resolution so when two people
edit the same piece of data at the same
time
they're both offline and then they
reconnect what do you do
a lot of you know a lot of the things
you'll see out there that call
themselves synchronization
the answer to that is you know some
variant of throw one of them away
and i don't want you to do that so we'll
talk about how you can avoid that
so to me the biggest exciting thing
about this
is enabling you know new classes of
mobile applications
so much of what people say mobile you
know isn't
it's not ready for um i think is and do
uh you know due largely to the fact that
you can't always rely on your connection
to the back end you know you're you're
only as reliable as
your you know your service provider
and reliability is not just about does
it work at all it's about
the perceived user experience and can
the user get into a rhythm with your app
and if it's like fast
fast fast oh that was weird why did it
take 30 seconds you know that that's
as bad as um you know not working at all
in some cases
one of the things um i guess another
question who here has
done any work with a nosql database
all right yeah this is um that that
turning point happened a year
or so ago i think um but one of the
things that we learned that surprised us
is that
you know i thought a lot of people were
using nosql for performance and scale
and it's true but when you do a survey
of people using nosql the number one
reason they come up with
you know the the the biggest uh thing
they like about it is
getting more developer productivity out
of being able to rapidly iterate the
um you know the data types and not
having to wait on
the dba to do a migration or something
before you can roll a new feature out
so by dropping that coordination
overhead among a development team
and people can just add features at the
code level that that seems to be the
biggest thing that
people like about using json database
so i mentioned before right you don't
want your user to be
kind of held hostage to their network
service providers
variable latencies uh and to me the
right way to think about that
is that your application and your device
is occasionally connected
so you know when you're so lucky as to
have uh
you know reachability to your back end
you should you know opportunistically do
everything that you can you know
reasonably based on what you know about
your user
so that when the user is using the app
they're never waiting on the cloud
so i hope that gives you enough of an
overview of what we're talking about now
i'm going to
drop in kind of one level deeper in the
developer
experience so the kind of the overriding
problem you get like let's say i've got
a nosql database with gigabytes of data
in the cloud
and i've got a little you know uh iphone
in my hand or an android device
you don't want all that data on the
phone right you just want what your user
cares about so how do you
efficiently take a subset of the data
and bring it down to the device
and you could do there's a whole bunch
of approaches that would work
that naive one would be just to filter
you know kind of each data item
in the cloud and say yes or no like this
user cares about it
and that logically works it gives you
the right stuff on the device but
it's not very performant because every
time a user connects you have to visit
all your data so
what we've done is taken you know
something like that approach but then
powered it on the back
end by indexes so that when the user
connects they're not
left waiting on you know a process
that's going to trickle them
one percent of the data after looking at
100 of it
so we call these channels and it's sort
of
you know a an intermediary between your
data and your users
if you imagine like a pub sub style
architecture a document can flow up into
the cloud
and be assigned to any number of
channels and a user can connect to the
cloud
and have the access rights to pull from
any number of channels and so
in any time the document set of channels
intersects with the user set of channels
they're going to get that data and
i talked about the sync gateway being
code you don't have to write
but uh we'll show some code later on uh
that is the code that you do write which
is kind of a user callback that you
inject into sync gateway
that allows you to map from data to
access control
changes as well as from data to which
channels it belongs to
so part of the sync gateway supports
authenticating and out of the box with
you know log in with facebook
log in with mozilla persona but it's
more generic than that at the lower
level and you can use your
ldap or you know whatever your existing
back-end system is
for for authentication as well so
one more kind of animation about
channels just to make sure that
uh it's it's easy to grock so
in this particular scenario we've got
one of these phones is
doing some writes and the function
running in the sync gateway
is looking at the data that comes in and
kind of filtering it so some clients are
getting some data
and and some clients are getting other
data
so here's the part where
i uh you know i hope to do
a little bit of a demo here but
hopefully an informative demo where we
can look at the code for the features as
we go
and so let's start out by you know
looking at which bits of code we're
going to care about
that's a little bit small don't worry
we'll zoom in on it but um
the you know the green sections happen
on the client and the blue thing happens
in the cloud
so we'll we're looking through the lens
of a phonegap application
the you know the way you would work
would be very similar if it was native
objective c code or native java code
and so we'll look at the you know crud
operations that
happen locally and uh look at how they
you know use the rest uh approach so
you know using all the verbs that you're
familiar with from a rest interface but
all on the device so there's no network
traffic it's just you know get put post
and delete
we'll also look at how you can you know
use that capability to
live update your ui and you when you're
doing a distributed data application you
have to
do data binding right you can't rely on
uh
your event driven stuff on the client to
trigger redraws because
events can come from you know remote
devices as well so if some
remote users changing data you need your
ui to reflect that as well as if the
local user is changing data and then the
last thing we'll look at
is that sync function callback
that i described earlier as the user
code that you
inject in the sync gateway that allows
you to um
you know i i like to uh say and it may
even be an understatement
but it's 10x less code than you would be
dealing with if you were going to try
and build the same application
you know from scratch on on your own and
i'd say 10x less code
than you'd deal with even if that same
application didn't have offline
capability if it was just like
you know old style web services it would
be 10 times more code and with this you
get
sync in addition to that if you tried to
build your own sync engine
you know call me next year when you're
two thirds of the way through it
so the uh you know i really believe that
at least in in my experience and my you
know the early users
that they're uh there's a lot of code
they're not writing
because they're able to you know think
about
uh moving data down the correct stream
rather than think about you know
transforming the data and
um you know how to you know take some
then coming in over the wire and put it
in the database and
and pull it back out and give it to
other clients
so to give you a sense of
this application that we're going to
look at it's really you know a hello
world application
that i designed to be the least amount
of code to show off you know most of the
features
of the embedded database so we've got
these json documents
that are created on the device one of
them
is you know describing a to-do list
and the other type is a document that
describes a task
that lives on a list so the
the list themselves you know have a
title and then they have kind of two
important fields for
access control they have an owner and
they have members
and so the owner of the list can go
browse into
uh you know a ui and check off who else
is a member of the list and that list
pops up on their phone
and then anyone who's a member of a list
can drop
you know tasks onto the list where the
only thing that really matters about a
task
from an access control standpoint is
which list it belongs to
but you know you also care of course
from a user standpoint whether or not
it's
checked off whether or not it's done and
and you know what the task is
so i'll kind of browse into this with
some
screenshots first and then i'll flip
over to the simulator and use the app so
you can get a sense of what we're
talking about
so again this is a phonegap app
we wrote a phonegap plug-in that allows
you to
drop couch-based light into your
phonegap container with you know one
line of shell just to say
a phone got plug-in ad blah
or you know if you're doing native stuff
you'll drag a framework over
into your xcode or add something to your
your maven repositories list on android
so uh this here is just a you know
html web view that is
running a view query for all the lists
and then rendering
it and when you type something up in the
top there
it creates a new list and you click that
and you browse down
into this task list and so you know
inside of a task list here
we have the ability to toggle check
boxes and
add more tasks so let's see
yeah here's my here's my simulator this
is a fresh
install so i can create
a you know i can create a list
you know called strange loop and i can
uh you know browse into it and and say
that
um you know i had apples for lunch and
um you know there's gonna be
like a really interesting um kind of uh
theater thing at the end of the day um i
don't know what we want to put on this
list
but there we go um and so
that's that's the basics of the the
crowd approach
um with this app so i'll show you
uh a couple more pieces of ui here
i'd like to be more interactive than
this as far as like syncing things from
over the network but at the very least
i can log in with my facebook account
and
let's see hopefully i get this right and
[Music]
it'll go to the cloud and uh
assuming my wi-fi is all good you know
it should go and pull in
everything uh
everything that's mine from the cloud so
let's hope that works
sometimes the delay can be you know
longer than you expect
so yay demo gods
um let me see
i might have i might have borked my
network by
you know doing something in the wrong
order as as i often do oh there we go
okay
so um
so this is all you know data that i had
created in the past
um that's not actually going to be a
picture of my pomegranate of a
pomegranate that's that's my ceo there
but
you can when you're on a real device
take pictures and they'll also
synchronize around
so uh this is
all on github you can go and build it
yourself and and play with it
um it synchronizes via
the stack that i showed earlier but like
mobile application developers in my
experience being one
would prefer not to like be the
administrator
of a cloud so it's running against an
experimental
cloud service that we offer where all
you have to do is you know put in
a name and a password and the 20 lines
of javascript that define your backend
and we give you a url that you can paste
into your app and
have it sync against the cloud
so let's look at the code that ran when
i toggled a check box
i really like javascript because it's
easy to fit you know the whole thing on
the screen easily
so when i click that check box
i you know the code the code that calls
this function goes and pulls out of the
dom
the id of the document that uh
or of the of that list item row and then
it's just going to do a get
against the you know an ajax call this
is kind of an abstraction for
ajax against localhost essentially
with the url of that particular document
and it parses the json
for you and so here we're just toggling
the checkbox and updating the timestamp
and then putting it back where we got it
so
there should be you know very little
mystery and hopefully you know most apps
even if they're data driven most of the
code isn't about the database right it's
just about
working locally so you make this change
and notice how like there's no code in
here to detect whether or not i'm online
or offline
you know there's no code branches here i
just work against the local database and
the local database
uh takes care of opportunistically
syncing with the cloud when it's
available
so uh you also notice that like as i was
adding items or checking items off
the ui refreshed actually let me back up
and show
one interesting thing about that uh
previous slide
so when the put succeeds you can see
that i basically take that success and
don't care
right i just ignore it with this empty
function here so this is where
if you weren't if you didn't have some
kind of live data binding
where the back end was sending events to
your ui layer
you would say oh i guess i should redraw
now because the user did something
but i don't bother because i know that
i'm going to redraw here
in this live update so i'm not showing
the code but
you know there's less code than this on
application launch time that
subscribes my javascript runtime to an
event feed from the database
and then all that you know little
subscription code does is say hey
anytime anything happens on the database
i'm going to call whatever function
happens to be registered
as this global variable and so uh
in this case we're inside of a
particular to-do view
uh task list and so every time the
database changes we're just going to
redraw that particular list
i could be you know i could be a little
bit more careful here and
figure out what the change actually was
and not do anything if the change isn't
relevant for this screen so there's
always room for more optimization
but here anytime the underlying database
changes i'm just running a
get request against another url in the
database and that's what this is an
abstraction for
with the range of keys that are relevant
for that to-do list
and then redrawing the html based on it
and apply in a few event listeners
so uh i guess yeah there's a couple more
slides about the
the code base for this app and then
maybe i'll take uh any questions that
come up about you know
what we've seen so far then we can drill
into the data structures
so we already saw that
facebook's great because that's what
your users want mostly but we also
support mozilla persona or any of the
other
you know basically anything that you can
authenticate with you might end up
having to
you know have your native
you know objective c code talk to your
app server
in order to get a session cookie or
something but then you can hand that
session cookie off to the
synchronization module and
it'll pick up from there
so you know one last little piece of
crowd code on the device here
and this is what happens when you know
you take a photo
the only thing you know all this is kind
of phonegap api like how much
um you know how big should my photo be
that kind of stuff which is what you
want to focus on right that's what your
users care about is
is these capabilities and the only
other uh you know aspects of this are
when the user you know when the image
data comes back from the camera
you're going to load the corresponding
document
via get request you'll just attach it
with a
jpeg content type and phonegap already
gives this back to you as a base64
encoded binary so it's ready to go
and then you can you know in this case
i'm using post i could use put
you get some flexibility about which
verbs you want to use but
the gist of it is i stick it back in the
database and once again
i'm not really interested in you know
getting a call back when that's done
because i know that my my live
you know query stuff is going to run so
so that's it for for the inside of the
app
but uh now we're gonna we're gonna look
at the the back end
um before we switch gears any questions
about the app
guts
so the question is about the access path
from uh
your application code to the database on
the device
and it's probably best i think you know
most apps are native so i'll answer it
from the native perspective first
from the native perspective it's an
embedded database so
you're calling native apis from your
code just like library code there's no
you know it doesn't even feel like a
network abstraction but there's
certainly no sockets or anything
happening
and then in html5 uh
on ios you know the nsurl protocol is
kind of awesome enough
that we're able to provide an nsurl
compatible kind of you know endpoint
that is not
socket based so it's also a completely
embedded call
does that answer the question
so you're talking about security um so
so well first of all so the concern is
that if we are
uh providing http like abstraction for
the database doesn't that mean that
you could potentially you know navigate
to a page
that would query your database without
your permission
and it it's in your control
so in if if you don't
load the optional rest module in then
that just plain can never happen because
that abstraction is not available
when you're writing a phonegap app it's
up to you to do the white list
of you know domains that your app is
going to
interact with over the network and so if
you do
an access star and the user somehow you
know clicks a link in your web view that
stays in in your app instead of going
over to safari
then i think theoretically that that
page could access
the same urls that your phonegap page is
accessing but you'd have to you know
make a couple of big security mistakes
on the way before that even started to
happen
um on android it's not quite as
as great of a story we're actually
moving android
more to the parity with what we do on
ios
a question in the back
that's a great question so the question
is about support for core data
essentially
so ns incremental store is a new api
that apple launched in ios 6 that allows
you to
use arbitrary storage for your core data
manage object models
and there's a user a community project
you know all this is open source and you
know go to our google group the
the mobile couch base google group and
you can you know interact with those
folks but
there's a guy who did that and it works
and
i tested it out on the airplane over
here and i'm hoping to get deeper into
it so
i'd like to see um core data support as
like a
you know one or two lines of take an
existing app right this is
the um what would be fun about this is
you've got some app that's in the app
store with millions of users or whatever
it's purely a data island right it's
just core data on the device let's say
and you want to you know you go and you
add
a couple of lines of configuration to
bootstrap couch baselight and connect it
up as the core data storage
and like boom now you have you know
millions of users worth of
json data in the cloud that you can do
uh you know queries across to learn more
about how your users are
using your application or to provide
value from external services etc
so to me that sounds like really a lot
of fun because you know it's just
whatever data was already there and now
you've added new value just by
you know shipping a new version of your
app that synchronizes to
uh couch-based in the cloud so let's
look at
at this i think it's you know sort of
like 20 something line
20 30 lines of javascript here this is
the entirety of the custom back-end
logic for that
to do light application that i was just
using
and so uh it's got you know the main
responsibilities
are access control routing documents to
channels
and just outright rejecting certain
updates of documents if they're not well
formed
and it turns out at least um this is
probably an 80
solution maybe more and there's
because we're not transforming the data
at any point
during that stream a whole lot of the
volume of code in like a rails app or a
node.js
app or something is about you know
hiding a field as it comes out of the
database before it goes to the api or
adding a new field when it comes in
via the api on the way to the database
and you don't do that and so
there's a lot less code so we'll drill
into
a couple of the big sections of this api
um
oh i'm really going to have to to go
fast after this
so here if a document is a task
we're going to say it has to have a list
id and if it doesn't we're going to
reject that update and it won't sync up
from the cloud
from the client so yeah you can hack
your client to do whatever crazy stuff
but it's not going to
go through our cloud to other clients
and then the last thing we'll do is
we'll take that lit
that that task item and we'll stick it
on the appropriate list for that list id
so that's pretty simple this is a little
bit more interesting
so not only does the sync function is it
able to route data to the appropriate
channels but it can
modify the access grants for a channel
so in this case we have a document that
is
of type list and so it has to have an
owner
and that require user line kind of
halfway down
says that if somebody's modifying this
list document it better be the owner of
the previous version of that list
document
and then the last bit of work it does
is make sure that anyone who's listed as
a member
can synchronize all the tasks that are
associated with that list
as well as putting this meta document on
that channel
as well so that you know the users can
see who the other members are
etc so with those
moving parts and you know there's a
little little bit more api surface area
that's available to you if you need it
the hope is that you should be able to
build something you know
almost as complex as a facebook or an
instagram or something
uh with you know maybe if you built all
of facebook it would be 500 lines of
code
instead of 20 but the idea is that you
know this should give you the moving
parts that you need in order to
build your back end and you're not
fussing around with you know crud and
request response cycles in your
application server
so yeah i'll save questions for that to
the end because i want to go off the
deep end here
and talk about the data structures that
you can use for conflict detection and
management
so vector clocks are well known and
popular we don't use them
we don't use them because they scale
with the number of processes that are
updating a given data item
so you know i also find them a little
bit hard to reason about
because you know whether or not
something is a conflict is
always relative to something else so in
this case
the updates those boxes that are in the
the non-shaded area
are conflicts relative to the update
that's right in the middle
of the of the graph there
and you know there are ways to prune
vector clocks so you can make up for
some of the scalability problems but
they're really
they're designed for systems where you
have a bounded number of clients
and you know kind of like how big your
system is in general
which you just don't know i mean you
hope you don't know how many users of
your mobile app you're going to have
when you launch it
so the other big key thing that we want
to do
is never throw data away i mentioned
that at the beginning so
uh that means that you know some of the
sync apis i've looked at
uh your client you know launches and
gets an input stream of some stuff from
the cloud
and you know some of that conflicts with
local updates that have been made in the
meantime
and you have to decide right then like
merge it or drop one
and that's that's your option it's
much i think more developer friendly to
give you also the option to do nothing
just defer the decision wait until you
know there's not just two conflicting
branches of a document but three or four
or five you know lots of opinions
and maybe merge on the client for
certain fields that need
human eyes to merge and have a script in
the cloud that merges
you know for things that can be
automated and so
uh by you know tracking um
instead of vector clocks which are kind
of based on who did it
we're more interested in what did they
do sort of content based
and so by tracking it in that way it
becomes cheaper to
never throw data away and allow you to
defer those decisions until you're
in the right position to do it so here
is i guess the glossary for this data
structure section
um logically the way we track each
revision of a document
you know each revision has a parent uh
revision
is kind of like git and so you've got a
generation counter
and then you've got a content hash and
the content hash is only a content hash
to allow us to do some certain
optimizations it could be randomly
generated but a content hash is better
and so with uh the rest of the glossary
is that
well on the wire in real life these look
like three dash
you know some content hash stuff
but for purposes of displaying it on the
screen and apologies in advance to
colorblind people but
i've mapped the hash numbers to
colors on the color wheel and so you
know
higher numbers are lighter let's say and
and lower numbers are darker
and the two other things you need to
know is that
anything in a yellow circle is the de
facto winner
and anything in a gray circle is a
conflicting version that we're not going
to throw away
until the user tells us to so when you
start out
it's as simple as i've got one client
who has the first generation of the
document
and there's lots of things that could
play out here but i played out a
scenario that illustrates the scaling
differences between this
and a vector clock so
we're going to synchronize that over to
the
to the other client and so now they both
agree about the state of the universe
and the second client is going to make
an update
so now the second client can garbage
collect
you know the first generation's body and
all it keeps is the metadata about that
so
so the only document bodies that are
still
existing are the first generation on one
client and the second generation another
client
will push back uh replication the other
way
and now the uh now they both agree right
it's pretty trivial there's no conflict
there because only one of them was
editing at any given time
and we'll just do that again so we'll
have this kind of ping pong scenario
and you get a document that is
three generations old and only has
uh you know one live copy source of
truth right because there's just no
conflicts to worry about
so the third generation is is the real
deal but um
your uh you know both your phones went
on different airplane rides or hey the
same airplane ride i don't know
they're disconnected for long enough for
both users to do some work and so one of
them does some purple work another one
does some green work
and now we have a conflict to deal with
what are we going to do when they learn
about
each other's stuff
well we'll synchronize that over there
and
in this case we've decided that green is
lighter colored so it's going to win
so the lighter colored one is the
provisional winner but we don't throw
away
the gray one we keep it around so you
can merge it later if you want to
we also if we were to say like hey keep
them both around and assign them equal
precedence
that's the same thing as forcing you to
deal with the conflict right away and
not allowing you to defer the decision
because
any get from your application is going
to get two versions and now all your
application code
is always having this error handling you
know threaded throughout it what happens
if i get two versions so we don't do
that
we if if you don't ask for conflicts we
just give you the yellow one
but we give you the same yellow one on
every device
so now the devices agree and they didn't
have to talk to agree because they just
picked the one that had the higher hash
value
for its content so
the this gives you this gives you this
distributed agreement but
you know now we have two things to keep
track of because we have two different
edits and we don't want to throw one
away
so let's bring in uh another client
that looks like it diverged back in the
third generation
of updates and what's going to happen
when that propagates back through
the the mesh of piers
well it turns out that that blue 4
that the client that was kind of long
lost and came back had created
is an even higher hash value than the
green 4
and so it becomes the winner and this
phone in the middle now knows
about you know three alternate realities
for the fourth generation of this
document and it's going to hang on to
the gray ones and present you
the yellow one if you you know don't
tell it that you
you know that you're aware of conflicts
and just to play this out a little bit
farther
let's say the user on this first phone
actually resolved a conflict they said
you know what that purple 4
that i don't need that anymore let's
throw that out i'll make a new
generation
based on you know the green four and so
now i have you know a five
um and i have a tombstone on four
so when that synchronizes back uh to
the client that you know has has learned
more than anybody else
at this point that tombstone
synchronizes
and five becomes the provisional winner
even though it's a darker color
than uh than the blue four because it's
a later generation
and so because we always give precedence
to
the latest generation you get uh
more or less read your own rights
because if you do a right it's going to
be
the child of whatever the previous
conflict winner was and so unless
someone else is doing rights
aggressively and synchronizing them in
like you know while you're in your ui
flow or something
you're going to read your own rights
because you always wrote the thing with
the highest generation number
so to play this out a little bit more
let's say now the um that long lost
client
gets a replication from the uh you know
the one that knows everything
and now they also agree and not only
they agree but the long-lost client
never
even had to learn about the four that
has the tombstone on it it's just
you know it's irrelevant so it didn't
get synced over
and uh you know the last thing that
we're going to want to do
eventually this chain of metadata you
know you want to prune it
just like you know any of these data
structures that
any kind of log that can grow without
bound but as long as we're kind of
you know pruning stuff that's old enough
not to matter for
your merge strategy then
pruning is relatively harmless so we're
able to
you know drop those old generations off
and and still give you you know more or
less what you would need in order to
correctly detect conflicts and merge
them
so for our use case we chose these
revision trees over vector clocks
vector clocks may be better in a
constrained environment like a data
center but
when you're fully disconnected you know
i think
revision trees are a better fit so
if you want to try this out
mobile.couchbase.com has all the
downloads
and you know find me afterward or
jayce on twitter or just start shouting
couchbase on twitter and i'll hear it
and
come help you or take feedback or
whatever so thank you